Isis we've been doing this every week
and we had another beheading video that
we could have shown you this week but I
know we've done two pretty graphic ones
over the last two weeks and
unfortunately these are not gonna stop
either so Isis just yesterday released
the video of the beheading of James
Wright Foley who is an American
photojournalist who's been missing in
Syria for about 22 months we're not
gonna show the video here because it's
been taken down from YouTube actually
Twitter already has issued a thing that
they're suspending accounts that put up
images of it I had to delete my tweet
about it we're gonna show you one screen
capture from the video just real quick
okay so you just so you know just
throwing this up so you know this is
real what we're talking about and
everyone this has already been confirmed
by our State Department and all that
so basically Isis is running rampant
through Iraq through Syria it seems to
me that we don't know what to do about
it and you know flags are being raised
in European capitals in England and in
France etc etc I want to get to what the
Pope had to say about this but what are
we supposed to what do we make of this
Isis we've never seen anything like this
is one of the the first times that Isis
directly is sort of warning the US and
saying we're coming after you yeah and
here's what we're gonna do we know this
is one of your people a journalist which
should you know really journalists
should be protected they think they're
there to report information they're you
know supposed to be unbiased sources of
information we really need journalists
so to put them in danger is absolutely
tragic
I'm pretty sure Isis doesn't operate
standard the thing that's really scary
too is that they say that they have yet
another American journalist and they're
threatening to do the same if we do not
stop our intervention and what blows my
mind too is that here we're intervening
in Iraq because we have a minority
population that is being decimated so
we're sort of entering the situation it
seems like on the outset or just at
first blush not for politically
motivated reasons this is an economic
condition this is because a Christian
minority is being persecuted so we're
there to help and this is what these are
the consequences it's absolutely tragic
so we've been talking about that a lot
so there were these 40,000 Yazidi that
were trapped on this mountain Isis was
surrounding them we had some airstrikes
it sounds like
we help some people but now apparently
they're still being raped and killed and
all that kind of stuff
what what are we supposed to do here
because it seems to me we created the
problem with the first war that we
shouldn't have gone into then Obama got
everybody out not that it not that we
should have stayed but maybe we left so
quickly that there was a power of a like
it's just a big freakin mess but what
what do we do now well I hate to realize
it but we're damned if we do damned if
we don't
and the more we try to help the worse it
gets and you know I know we're gonna
talk about the cool Pope who says you
know maybe forces need it now and for so
long it's you know we've stuck to our
guns and we do not negotiate with
terrorists and we don't do this we kind
of do exactly but what we're doing it's
not working and we're losing our people
and that shouldn't be what we're faced
with when we're trying to intervene and
help a situation so I think that force
is needed at this point and it needs to
be in a different capacity than what
we've been trying yeah all right so
before we get to the to the Pope for all
the people that say you know we
shouldn't go back in and we shouldn't do
anything what would you say to them
because it sounds like both you were
kinda at least for air strikes or
something and that's I know the YouTube
commenters always got what you Americans
screws everything up either way well
what would you say to them we have to
get our people like I can't leave them
there we can't have another beheading we
can't just oh you're going to pull out
now whatever happens to the rest of our
people that are there and the rest of
the people that are being hurt we don't
care anymore it just it logically that
doesn't make sense yeah I think it's
very sort of complex moral territory
here there are many philosophical
implications you know Vanessa you
mentioned we have to get our people but
do we not have a responsibility as one
of the largest super powers in the world
to also protect innocent people in
children these children are being
murdered you know they're being starved
to death and and yell at you and say
well you're an interventionist and let
everybody else do it why doesn't the UN
do it but I think it's been proven that
pretty much unless the u.s. does
something nobody does anything
unfortunately which is why we're damned
if we do yeah and you know there are
some reports that say that the US
airstrikes were critical in taking back
the mussel dam and having having the
Cordish people take control of it you
know if if Isis would have taken control
on the
to potentially starve the entire popular
vote portion of the population or they
could have used it to essentially you
know flood a bunch of cities they could
have done so much damage and so I think
there we saw sort of a situation where
we absolutely had to intervene yeah but
it's a really tough question do I want
my you know soldiers my my people my
resources my you know our country's
money to be devoted here no absolutely
not I'd rather the situation not be here
but I think in some ways we have to
consider the possibility that we are
partially responsible for the situation
in the first place and we should act
accordingly yeah I think we're all
pretty much on the same page there and
then the Pope chimed in and we've got
the quote the Pope said in these cases
where there is an unjust aggression by
Isis I can only say that it is licit to
stop the unjust aggressor i underscore
the verb stop I'm not saying bomb or
make war just stop and that means that
can be used to stop them must be
evaluated so obviously the Pope doesn't
want to come out and be like bomb these
[ __ ] that's not how Pope's
operate but he pretty much is calling
for military action there right like
that's pretty much he can't say it
outright but I think he's pretty much
saying you know prayer doesn't work
really like isn't that you know they had
the prayer thing for Gaza in Israel a
month ago but when it really comes down
to it we can all sit and pray that the
Yazidis are not going to be slaughtered
or that they're gonna release this other
journalists that they have but that
probably won't do anything but feel free
to take the other counterpoint well I
think in in his mind I won't speak for
the Pope but I someone's been who does
pray very often and I believe that in
your prayer things are revealed to you
so I think in his prayer maybe it was
revealed to him that you know these are
the actions that may need to take place
in order for the peace to be restored or
in order for the outcome that is desired
you know to happen happens and so I
don't think he's saying whoo I'm done
with this prayer thing you know it ain't
working let's bow
but I think he's saying you know I have
my faith I have my beliefs but at the
end of the day we still need physical
action here on earth I can pray to my
Heavenly Father but we still need
physical action here on earth to go in
and stop these forces I don't yeah I
definitely agree with you in that and
you know he's not saying that we should
stop for anything like that he doesn't
even mention I'm but he is saying just
stop right and he emphasizes that
emphasizes that he means not war not
bomb like he is very clear that he's not
calling for military intervention he's
just saying we need to figure out a way
to make this right or is he just isn't
that just placating like I can't go and
call for war so I'm gonna say just stop
that doesn't really mean it what does
that mean really just stop like you
could stop but Isis isn't gonna stop and
I don't think they're taking advice from
the Pope are they like they don't really
care coaches right zena's they're
persecuting the Christian minority I
[Music]
know yeah I think I I think what he
wants to say in saying stop is that I
don't have the answers is what he's
saying but in an ideal world if we're
looking at a utopian society yes let's
make it stop and he can say that and he
can still be the Pope and he can you
know still talk about prayer but he is
still looking at this situation and
trying to put his own input into it I
guess I can't like I thank you for the
pony prayer and bomb some good but just
stop like that sounds really nice like
just stop solution yeah all right so my
final thought on this so the the
censoring issue because you know when
Twitter censored these videos yesterday
and I had to delete my tweet about it
and they were suspending accounts not
just telling people have to take them
down they were actually suspending
accounts you know everyone kept saying
well we're just giving them propaganda
and I completely disagree to me it's
like we have to show this stuff so that
we understand what we're fighting here
or at least what's going on in this
other part of the world where do you
guys fall out on that that we should
that that were just propagating it if we
if we retweet it or that we should just
not be showing it out of either the
respect to the debtor it's more so about
what the viewer takes from it I think
it's a video that
I haven't watched myself because I can't
you know how much I cry I cannot watch
that video but I think the video needs
to be talked about it needs to be spread
and people need to know this is what is
happening yeah and like nowadays if you
don't take a picture with Beyonce and
put it on Instagram no one believes you
saw Beyonce so you don't see this video
people will not believe that this is
actually what we're facing and so it's a
bit of a hypocrisy for Twitter to
suspend these accounts and be enraged
when people can say whatever they want
and threaten your life and they can
still have an account right and so it's
a little bit of a gray area but don't
spread the video so you can hashtag it
in get followers like that's demeaning
but this is information and you are a
news source so yes it needs to be a
discussion I tend to agree with you
Vanessa so I think we need to have
access to this information needs to be
available to us and perhaps it's our
responsibility to educate the public and
people who have access this information
so that it's not made a mockery I think
so that we understand it unfortunately
you know let's you mentioned Dave when
we have this type of information and it
spreads and through social media forums
and it goes viral then and unfortunately
sometimes fuels the terrorist
organizations
you know motives and desire to do this
even that's what they're saying yeah so
can potentially perpetuate the situation
but I would say we can we should err on
the side of having more information
versus having information taken away
from us and being blinded to what's
happening we can't act if we don't know
what's happening
[Music]